[Musique]
il est 5h Paris s'éveille régulièrement
à la descente de l'avion de ligne un
agent de l'antenne de Paris accueille
des réignonnais bonjour madame LEB vous
AZ fait bon voyage oui bien oui bonjour
bienvenue à Paris hein ouioujour merci
pour l'accueil Merci à VOUS chaleureux
oh chaleureux avec la fraîcheur qu' a
dehors
dans dans les pieds on va aller prendre
la voiture au parking ah c'est bien il y
a une voiture c'est bien voilà et je
vais vous emmener donc à votre centre
d'hébergement à Suren c'est la maison
des parents de Foch m'assur donc à
domicile absolument alors pas pour
chaque arrivée mais lorsque la personne
n'a pas de famille à Paris n'a pas de
moyens d'être transféré sur le centre
d'hébergement ou à l'hôpital pas
d'ambulance le l'antenne de Paris vient
à à à l'aéroport pour les accueillir et
les emmener sur Paris nous représentons
la chaleur rayonnaise la solidarité
rayonnaise qui est extrêmement
importante voilà le sourir heureusement
qu'elle est
[Musique]
là originaire de Saint-Anne le fils de
maryine est atteint de mucovicidose
depuis 26 ans c'est donc des
allés-retours perpétuels pour trouver
une solution médicale allez hop on est à
Foche oui il y a l'hôpital juste en face
là c'est la maison des parents c'est là
que je viens
ou assez souvent on va
[Musique]
dire le problème d'un vol matinal est
une arrivée avant l'ouverture des
portes
allez fa pas la porte parce que sinon il
reste dehors pas dans le chemin alors ça
va comment super tu revenu oui ça a été
je reviens à la Maison des Parents ah cé
ouais il a eu sa greffe mon garçon ce
matin-là le déplacement est particulier
après 26 ans d'attente sonans enfants
comme elle aime laappelé a été greffé
enfin de la joie et une lueur d'espoir
madame le beauoui bienvenue donc dans à
la Maison des Parents Foche merci donc
je vais vous remettre le le pack accueil
que département là comme j'ai
unehabitude remet donc à chaque
accompagnant de malade qui arrive en mes
téléphone donc le petit téléphone très
utile très utile ou très utile et plus
économique que son téléphone de la
Réunion qui est à cause du rowing euh
donc des appels très utiles oui voilà
donc le plan de de de de Paris les
titres de transport le livret de
l'accompagnant dans lequel vous avez
donc remplir votre numéro donc de
téléphone c'est un petit livret pour qui
vous rappelle un petit peu les données
l'adresse de la la résidence où nous
sommes la maison des parents de
l'hôpital Foch rappel du numéro vert
euh il faut bien noter aussi donc le
billet retour pour que de toute manière
nous on suit voà de toute façon pour le
retour je vous dire hein voilà bonne
semaine à avance quand à ce que je pars
et voilà VO donc voilà pour le livr un
petit questionnaire bah pour nous aider
à mieux à améliorer ce
[Musique]
dispositif après avoir pris possession
des lieux pour ce séjour de plus d'un
mois marilyine attend avec impatience de
voir son fils l'après-midi dans
l'hôpital le Necker situé juste de
l'autre côté de la rue une chance quand
les difficultés de logement et leur prix
au centre de
Paris il y avait besoin de sucre ici
sont pas il ont pas de sucre si café Le
Lion café c'est pour
moi alors petit bois
de et puis ça c'est le Royal boisan
grain
rouge VO chaque année plusieurs
centaines de personnes socialement en
difficulté sont pris en charge et
accompagné par le Conseil départemental
côté maladie tout ça c'est la souffrance
mais après il y a des rires il y a des
pleurs mais aussi c'est c'est pour nous
un lieu qu'on rencontre pas mal de gens
on côtoi des des familles ça va retenir
tout ça ah des bons souvenirs des bons
souvenirs même
si on est là pour se soutenir des uns
des autres une action sociale qui
redonne un peu d'espoir c'est le moment
que ça fait longtemps ça que N t en ça
ben mais il remercie la médecine le bon
Dieu et
tout c'est c'est c'est c'est énorme pour
nous quoi tout ce qui est arrivé là il
souhaite qu'il arrive à d'autres
familles que moi g sa greffe que moi que
d'autres familles aussi trouve ce
bonheur trouve ce bonheur c'est une
nouvelle vie pour
[Musique]
lui